But this loss of protection with the
Dos-like structure is simply unacceptable for a
general purpose operating system today. On the
other hand, the monolithic structure gives the protection
that is so important. At the same time, what it strives to do is also
(no period) It reduces the potential for
performance loss by consolidating all the services in
one big monolithic structure. That is, even
tough and application has to go from its
address space, into the operating system's address
space in order to get some service, It
is usually the case that the operating
system has several components and they have to
talk to one another in order to provide
the service that an application wants. Think about
the file system, for instance. You make a call
to the file system to open a file and the
file system then may have to call the storage module
in order to find out where exactly a file is
residing. And it may have to contact The memory
manager module to see where it wants to bring in
the file that you want to open and see the
content of. So in this sense there's infraction that's going to
go on under the cover. Inside the
operating system between components of the operating
system. In order to satisfy a single
service call from an application. So this monolithic
structure insures that even though... We have to go from an application into the
operating system's address space. Once you're inside
the operating system's address space, then potential for
performance loss is avoided by the consolidation
of all the components that comprise the
operating system. But what is lost in
the monolithic structure (no period) That is the
ability to customize the operating system service
for different applications. This model of one
size fits all, so far the system
service is concerned with the monolithic structure shutsoed
the opportunity for customizing the operating service
for the needs of different applications. Now,
you may wonder why do we need
to customize the operating system service for different
applications? Why not one size fits all? Why is there an issue? If you look
at a couple of examples, the need
for customization will become fairly obvious. For example,
Interactive video games. The requirement of applications,
that are providing a video game experience
for the user. Or consider another application,
which is computing, All the prime numbers. You
can immediately see that the operating system
needs for these two classes of applications
are perhaps very different. On the one hand, for the little kid who is playing
a video game, the key determinant of
a good operating system would be responsiveness. How
quickly the operating system is responding to his
nifty moves when he plays his video game.
On the other hand, for the programmer
that wrote this prime number computing application, the
key determinant of performance is going to be sustained
CPU time that's available for crunching his application.